ولا زلنا نحتفل معكم بيوم المراه فهذه
الفقره مخصصه لانجازات النساء في عده
مجالات في التعليم تقود اليوم النساء 48
جامعه من افضل 200 جامعه في العالم اهمها
معهد شوست التكنولوجيا وجامعه اوكسفورد
البريطانيه وهذه زياده بنسبه 41% عن مكان
عليه الوضع قبل خمس سنوات
ويطبقارب ستقود نساء في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا اليوم بعضا من اكبر الشركات
في المنطقه وبعدهن ترك بصماتهن على
المستوى الدولي منهن اثنين في قائمه اقوى
مئه امراه في العالم 2022 وفي الفضاء خصصت
ناسا صفحه على موقعها الرسمي لتسليط الضوء
على انجازات النساء في المجال ومنذ عام
1963 60 سافرت 72 امراه الى الفضاء منهن
42 عملنا في رحلات طويله الامد ولعلنا
نشهد اول امراه عربيه في الفضاء خلال
العام الجاري
[موسيقى]
ونرحب بسهل من جده رينادويهي من شمال
لبنان واحلام العبدلي من تونس وابدا معك
بيسوها والمراه وصلت الى الفضاء
كل عام وانت بالف خير اولا
نحن كنساء يسها ويسعد صباحك كمان اليوم في
صباح العربيه وكل عام وانت بالف خير صباحك
يا رب سهى ومن جدا معكم الى بيروت الى
بترون بالتحديد شمال لبنان يسعد هالصباح
من البترولنا رينا دويهي رنا بالانتخابات
اللبنانيه الاخيره كان في كتير تعويل على
التغيريين انه اقلوا يحققوا مساله
المساواه بين المراه والرجل خصوصا هذا
الجدل الشائك حول وضع المراه اللبنانيه في
لبنان اليوم ماذا تقولين في ذلك
نعم بلبنان البطلات كتار وبكل المجالات
المراه موجوده رغم كل الحقوق المنقوصه
وانا اخترت اليوم على سبيل المثال للحصر
الدكتور نجاه صليبه هي اتيه من المجال
العلمي ومتخصصه في يعني التلوث البيئي
ومشاكل البيئه حسب 2019 كانت على لائحه
النساء الاكثر تاثيرا في العالم على يعني
لائحه بي بي سي لانها وصلت كما تقولين الى
الندوه البرلمانيه عبر صفوف التغريد
التغيريين ونجاه صليبه تبيت اليوم منذ
اكثر من شهر ونصف تحت قبه البرلمان
اللبناني دون كهرباء ودون تدفئه نعم هي
اقرت اعتصاما مفتوحا هي وزميلها النائب
ملحم خلف
اعتصاما مفتوحا لحين انتخاب رئيس
للجمهوريه ومن ذلك الحين نجاه صليبه باقيه
في المجلس لا تغادره الا للاستحمام وعند
الضروره تتداول مع زميلتها حليمه قعقور
على المبيت ويتعاون زملائه من النواب
التغيريين على مدهم بالاساسيات من الطعام
ومن الملبس واهم من كل شيء من شحن ومصابيح
للاناره لانه الكهرباء مقطوعه بالمجلس
لاكثر من 12
ساعه هذا الاعتصام يعني كتراجعت الاهتمام
الاعلامي بتغطيته الى انها نجاه لم تتراجع
ورغم انه لم يؤدي الى اي حل في ملف الفراغ
الرئاسي حتى الان ولكن وكما يقال الثوره
انثى ومعها بدات طيب من لبنان العيد ما
فيني غير ما اعيدكم وعيد كل نساء العالم
ايضا
تدخل التاريخ كذلك من ابواب الرياضه
نتعارف معك على لاعبه التنس التونسيه دخلت
التاريخ كافضل لاعب عربيه وافريقيه بعد
فوزها ببطوله مدريد المفتوحه للتنس اليك
احلام
كتبت وكتبت فلم يبقى حرف وسفت وصفت فلم
يبقى وصف اقول اذا باختصار
بلادي نساء ونصف بهذه الابيات للشاعر
العظيمه التونسي الصغيره اولاد احمد
احييكم
وكل زميلات في صباح العربيه وفي قناه
العربيه ونحيي المراه عبر العالم الكادحات
الصميدات القويات المتميزات وانس جابر خير
مثالا لهن اليوم بطله في يوم المراه
العالمي هي انس جابر التي جاءت من عائله
متوسطه لتقتحم رحاب رياضه الاثرياء فغيرت
قوانينها يعني بصفه مجازيه وجعلتها انظار
العالم تنطلق وتثبت على تونس وعلى العرب
وعلى القاره الافريقيه بمضربها في
ويمبلدون صنعت التاريخ وحققت انجازا كان
الى وقت قريب حكرا على نساء وعلى شعوب
اخرى انس جابر لا تغيب عن العمل الخيري لا
تغيب عن ترميم المدارس لا تغيب عن الشلحه
الذهمم الاطفال الصغار بان يصنعوا بدورهم
بطولتهم وان يصنعوا حلمهم وقصتهم الجميله
لانس جابر ولكل امراه متميزه وجريئه في
يوم المراه العالمي وفي كل يوم كل تحيه
والف تحيه واجمل التحيه لكن زميلتي في
صباح العربيه المتميز دائما بالاطلاله
النسويه مع القياده ايضا النسويه والذكريه
المشتركه نحي الجميع يعني احلام احسنت
احسنت وعجزنا عن الرد والوصف لما قلت شكرا
جزيلا لك وكنت تحدثتي عن وزيره السعاده
التونسيه ونحن اليوم في حاله سعاده طبعا
نحن في حاله السعاده دائمه مع بعضنا البعض
في صباح العربيه ولكن اليوم السعاده اكثر
شكرا جزيلا احلام العبدلي من تونس
رينادويه من البترون وايضا سهى الوعل من
جده شكرا لكم